grab a pill and meet me down by the dick
doc because we have episode 3 of
american horror story double feature and
this is our bloodiest one yet in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
red tide clues and theories on what
might happen and greater connections to
the ahs universe so pour yourself some
delicious blood and make sure to like
and subscribe seriously only 12 of you
are subscribed because we're getting
right into it well it hasn't been one
minute into the episode and doris has
already mentioned lyme disease now i
want to get her tasted for
lime and rabies in my episode 1 and 2
breakdown i'll leave a link to that in
the description below i talked about how
lyme disease may be the key to thwarting
off and or poisoning those who drink its
tainted blood of course doris is
concerned her daughter may have it after
witnessing her eat a dead rabbit at the
end of episode 2. and if things couldn't
get worse for the gardener family chief
burleson has stopped on by saying some
of the townsfolk noticed a young girl
covered in blood coming from the
cemetery i'm not sure if anyone else
noticed this but they spelled her name
wrong on the name tag on the official
ahs poster and on imdb it's
b-u-r-l-e-s-o-n and i'm not exactly sure
if this is a mistake or if it was
addressed and just cut from the show
burleson is the new chief in town so
it's totally possible someone messed up
the name while making her new tag we
also get a better view of the chief's
provincetown police insignia which says
pilgrim's first landing place with the
year 1620 a different date on the
provincetown founding marker here which
claims 1686.
1620 is the date the mayflower landed in
provincetown and the main flower is even
mentioned in this episode unless your
family came over on the mayflower or
launched off falmouth to hunt a whale or
two
you'll always be an outsider i'd be
surprised if a flashback to that era
doesn't happen this season the chief
wants to talk to alma after the markings
on the dead rabbit look similar to those
of a dead hustler found along the shore
this is referring to the man harry
killed at the end of episode 2 but when
the chief goes to collect alma doris
collapses and falls down the stairs an
event which the doctor at the hospital
later says were caused by false
contractions brought on by stress for
safety doris will have to stay in the
hospital for the next four to five days
she has a history of having miscarriages
this leaves harry a lot of time to get
into trouble he ends up giving alma some
money for the vending machine but she
only has her eyes on those sweet sweet
packets of blood we saw her taking one
of those black pills last episode which
has resulted in her having an insatiable
taste for blood harry lies to doris
telling her he'll take alma back to new
york but he has no intention to do so
the allure of the black pill and his
work is too much and if he keeps this up
for the rest of the season and doesn't
see the error of his ways this season
will likely end in tragedy alma really
creeps me out she has this almost
sociopath type quality where the only
thing she cares about is her art she
doesn't care about her mom and that
people who don't have talent could just
disappear one day and it wouldn't matter
it's tough to say if this is the result
of the pill or if she's always been like
this since every time she said something
along those lines it's been post pill so
alma makes a deal with her dad not to
take the pill if he doesn't either and
that lasted for about two seconds alma
even catches him doing it and demands
one too which him being the number one
dad gives it to her it makes me think
about what austin said in episode 2 that
once you take the pill you can't go back
to normal it's like trying to screw with
a dick full of novocaine once you take
the pill you can't get hard without it
at the muse harry and alma discuss the
situation harry's concerned about the
side effects the pill could have on a
younger girl not to mention with his
work he can generate scripts for 3
months then try to get off the pill but
with her she needs to be on it all the
time to play music in the meantime he
tells her to never feed off anyone he'll
bring the blood to her and there's just
such a great attention to detail here
like alma drinking a shirley temple
named after a child entertainer in the
arts plus the addition of grenadine
which gives it that red tinge harry like
belle noir in austin uses craigslist to
hunt his next victim an addict on the
outskirts of town who likes to show off
her panties unfortunately for harry he's
the one being hunted finding himself
tied up in the basement of a horny
couple who makes sexy snuff films it's
so gross i hope you didn't catch tony
lubing himself up with a can of crisco
tony here is played by actor blake
shields who you might remember from the
american horror stories feral episode
starring cody fern what tony and this
girl don't realize is that harry can use
his fang teeth he got from lark last
episode to chew through his confines and
surprise attack them feeding off the
woman shooting tony and putting some
blood in a red thermos to later feed to
alma i sure hope harry deleted that tape
recording ursula shows up unannounced at
harry's doorstep she's harry's hollywood
agent who's been fielding nothing but
offers for harry after he turned in his
best work yet hell even joaquin phoenix
wants to star in his next feature she
comes to tell him that quentin tarantino
wants him to write his first limited
series which has already been greenlit
by hulu hulu being the streaming
platform you can watch ahs on hashtag
not an ad it's even hinted that quentin
used the black pills to write his movies
and now that he's off them he needs
someone like harry to do the job ursula
will be staying at the lands and inn
which also happens to be the name of a
book we've seen harry have on his desk
which takes place in provincetown that
night at the muse ursula cringes at a
duet between austin and belle noire
clearly she doesn't understand good
music her interaction with them doesn't
go over too well and even mickey gets
the cold shoulder i like my men with
considerably darker complexions and a
lot less meth running through their
veins the next day however mickey tracks
her down by the beach hearing from the
bellhop at the end that she's a big
hollywood agent we know that mickey has
always dreamed of being a writer and
he's been writing like crazy ever since
he took one of bell's stolen black pills
this gamble pays off for mickey as later
that night ursula reads his script and
is blown away but more importantly
ursula starts to notice something weird
going on in provincetown and she wants
to know exactly what it is sorry homeboy
but there is something weird going on
out here and i want to know what it is
she jokes that it could be aliens making
people so talented which is a slight nod
to part two of double feature which
includes aliens ursula goes on to note
that not only have mickey and harry
turned in amazing work she recognized
belle and austin from the bar as being
famous artists as well and with the
promise of mickey achieving his dreams
of being a famous writer mickey tells
her about the black pills if ursula had
a steady stream of those she could
create her own boutique agency and make
millions so she tasks mickey with
getting some or his scripts go in the
garbage at belle's house we see the red
light on we saw this in previous
episodes but we're not a hundred percent
sure what it means like it could be
something to ward off the pale creatures
or a sign that the person inside has
gone off to feed which is where belle is
going right now i like how her house
number is just one off from 666. so
mickey breaks into her house and i love
how in this episode we'll see him break
into a lot of things a total role
reversal from home alone after sorting
through belle's vibrators ew mickey
eventually stumbles upon the pills and
takes some meanwhile belle austin and
harry find a new group of addicts to
feed off and harry takes the opportunity
to steal some blood for alma this
triggers bell to hold a gun to him
asking who the blood is for and instead
of harry being like oh i wanted some for
later he immediately tells her it's for
his daughter who took one of the pills
bell tells him alma's a liability and
that she's not to be given any more
before he's dropped off but when austin
and bell are alone bell says harry must
be killed this is a position that is
later echoed by the chemist who wants
the entire family killed at the dick
dock mickey's thirst for blood leads him
in a very sloppy fight with a hustler
named beefy beefy's corpse will later
wash ashore and be found by local police
belle visits mickey at his shack wanting
answers about the missing pills mickey
doesn't deny it saying the pills have
made him just like her and austin
talented but bell scoffs at the
comparison
for
honey
paper airplane and not a 747. if mickey
wants more of those pills he'll have to
do bella favor kill ursula after all it
was ursula who criticized her singing i
don't like it when people criticize my
singing she also demands for every one
of his kills two to three thermos is
full of blood maybe bell noir just wants
some extra blood around but so far i've
associated thermoses with alma and since
belle noir exclaims in this episode her
love for young blood i wouldn't be
surprised if she has other plans for
alma as burleson takes care of the
latest body to wash ashore we get our
first introduction of dennis o'hare's
holden vaughn he witnessed the murder
but was too far to get a good glimpse of
the killer the interesting thing here is
that holden is a famous interior
designer doris is also an interior
designer i wonder if these two will meet
in the previews we saw holden stumble
upon some severed body parts while
walking his greyhounds he tells burleson
the reason he's in town is that he can't
go back to new york because one of his
greyhounds died there and he needs a
period of mourning does this mean this
shot is a flashback or does holden have
more than two dogs with holden being a
famous designer does that mean he's also
been taking the black pills so mickey's
gone full home alone with that crowbar
on his way to murder ursula but when he
finds out ursula has already lined him
up to be the writer for the next speed
racer reboot he's like murder who now
ursula wants to know where those black
pills came from so if mickey wants this
writing up he'll have to take her to
them at the chemisos we can see the door
knocker is of a mermaid we know part one
is called red tide and the preview
materials as well as ryan murphy himself
have hinted at sirens and sea creatures
but to be honest we haven't got a lot of
that yet maybe they're holding out on us
or maybe the chemist's black pills are
somehow connected to the sea regardless
ursula tells her that she can make a lot
of money selling these in hollywood and
proposes a partnership a partnership
which the chemist rejects with the
chemist not wanting to become super rich
it makes me wonder what her true
motivations are why give out these pills
seemingly for free why make them in the
first place it's also interesting to
note that the chemist does not keep a
copy of the recipe anywhere so if she
dies so too does the recipe with it the
chemist tells belle and austin to kill
ursula mickey and all of the gardner
family so it looks like things are going
to be pretty hairy for harry in the
upcoming weeks with harry needing to
obtain more blood he asks ursula to
babysit alma because what could go wrong
when asking someone to babysit your
bloodthirsty daughter the chief is
actually watching the house and when
harry leaves she pays a visit to alma
she knows something is up and asks if
it's some sort of cult or blood virus
both nods to previous seasons of ahs
cult and hotel she even remarks on how
alma and doris have old sounding names
which she surmises is because of
nostalgia this is a fun non to alma and
doris both being names used in previous
seasons of ahs alma walker from asylum
and doris karen's goodwin in roanoke the
chief says she's taking in alma to the
station and when harry gets there he'll
be arrested but before she can alma
murders her in cold blood but what's
even more disturbing is when harry comes
home to find burleson's dead body ursula
and alma are playing a casual game of
gin rummy ursula now has some leverage
on harry in her quest to find out what's
going on he'll have no choice but to do
what she says now that she knows about
alma killing the chief of police in
their very own living room also pretty
sad that we didn't get a tb karen
appearance this week that's the end of
episode 3 which sees a lot of moving
pieces of the story shifting if the
trailer for episode 4 is out soon i'll
try to do a breakdown on that and look
for even more clues thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you